and are some people inherently bad and
what he says about that so if you can
play this
do you think if a sammy if a michael if
a frank
if a
leonetti had your
parenting and your upbringing meaning
your parents your mom and dad
do you think they would have gone
straight or do you think it's in them to
say no i'm still gonna go do the
shortcut what do you think it's a little
hard to say about the people you don't
know so let me tell you about michael
because i know michael the best there's
no doubt that if michael had the right
direction and the right parenting he'd
have been a very successful
legitimate
something important
a decent guy
respected his father which is a good
thing except it was the wrong father to
respect right
and and i'm going to guess on the others
just what i know of i think
there are a few people that are
genetically inherently bad evil
even
but most people are shaped that way by
circumstances i i think
i could have gone the other way if my
parents kept me in brooklyn and
i mean i hope i wouldn't have i hope
something else would have stopped me but
there's a chance i could have gone in
the other direction so when i prosecuted
people
it was always a
sense of empathy for them
so they were quite human i mean they
were human people
some of them were
gotti
was a guy who liked killing
there's something sinister and sadistic
about john yeah you believe that
i know that how about sammy
don't know
okay
don't know don't know
what do you think about what do you have
to say
i i don't know i think he looked gay
when he was
moved
he was [ __ ] married but he i don't
know what the [ __ ] you're not a fan of
rudy i'm not a fan of rudy no okay i'm
not a fan of rudy listen i'm not i'm not
against cops and prosecutors
i i'm against
when
you think
what you did is harmless
you're an italian
he's an italian i was so right
what you did to your own kind
on many occasions you have no flaws
your mom and dad was perfect
depending on their upbringing that's an
insult to me
my
my upbringing was impeccable
from my family
i'm the total opposite of what they were
and i don't think so i think i got a
good side
and i think i got the good side from
them
but
when you sit down and you make judgments
like that i don't know of course you
don't know me from a [ __ ] hole in the
world so you can't really make a proper
decision
he actually says nice things about
michael michael must have paid him off
to say these [ __ ] things but he said
some nice things about michael
but i don't like rocket tears out money
yeah yeah racket is our buddy so he's
looking at a record here so anyway
what i was what i was going to say is
that
the part of saying he looked up to his
father that's a good thing
but not that father so he's knocking his
father so i don't think that's a good
thing to even say if you liked him and
he did a good thing and he said a good
thing i think sonny was a good thing
a good father
in a good way
in a different way he was a gangster he
was the ultimate type of gangster
he didn't instill anything
negative in a way
i think he instilled that he loved them
in his way
i don't think i instilled anything
negative to my son and my daughter i
probably did
in our way
maybe your mother and father maybe your
mother and father or your mother and
father
and and
put something in your mind in a way
and we're gonna blame them because
you're not 100
like he wants you to be
i don't i don't buy that
now there's a lot of things your mother
and father teach you
that
are wrong but they mean well
there's a difference he don't understand
that
there's a
they'll tell a girl what to do
[Music]
maybe they're wrong
maybe it won't work
for them
but they meant well
now the times change
so it may not work out well for the girl
or the guy or whatever
when you get into families and you talk
about families and things like that
each person is an individual
nobody does exactly like their mother or
father teaches them
nobody does
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]